we have now for several weeks been
covering we could call it a rupture we
could call it a crack a crevasse maybe
between radical republican congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor green and radical
republican congresswoman Lauren bobert
or bobair as rokana likes to call her
The Divide is deepening take a look at
this
unhinged is the word that Lauren bobert
is now using to describe Marjorie Taylor
green there is a good Associated Press
article bobert's backers urge her to
tone down the nasty rhetoric but when
you do a search for unhinged you see
uh bobert saying the following I have
been asked to explain Marjorie Taylor
Green's beliefs on Jewish space lasers
or why she showed up to a white
supremacist conference I'm just not
going to go there bobert said over the
phone as she wrote in a car winding
through the high Canyons near her
hometown of silt before the speakership
vote she wants to say all these things
and seem unhinged on Twitter so be it so
be it so then we hear from Marjorie
Taylor green and Marjorie Taylor green
says that Lauren bobert's approach to
selecting a speaker isn't serious take a
listen I think the American people no
matter how you vote are sick and tired
of drama and this is nothing but drama
we're we're on multiple days now with
multiple candidates from this group so
I'm not sure how Lauren bobert on one
hand can demand so much out of Kevin
McCarthy and then demand nothing out of
someone else and be willing to vote for
them to be speaker that's not serious
um I don't think that's leadership and I
really see it as more obstruction than
progress yeah this is absolutely
fascinating you know I know that many
many people sadly even in my audience
are using the sort of misogynistic term
cat fight to describe this oh it's a cat
fight uh whoa uh this is actually a
really interesting political Rift and
I'm going to tell you why
before this Rift the Republican Party
had Maga and they had non-maga they had
the pro-trump Republican party and the
anti-trump Republican party so you had
very very sort of neatly defined for the
most part on one side uh Mitt Romney
Adam kinzinger Liz Cheney the anti-trump
people and then you had Maga and Lauren
bobert was part of Maga and Marjorie
Taylor green was part of Mecca what you
are seeing now is an intra Maga Civil
War you still have Mitt Romney right and
Mitt Romney is not part of this bobert
thing and Mitt Romney is not part of
this Marjorie Taylor green thing now
he's also in the Senate so he doesn't
vote for the speaker and in that sense
he's also separate but now you see a
subsequent division happening within
Maga and what's going on is that there
are basically two bets that you can make
and Marjorie Taylor green is making one
bet and Lauren bobert is making a
different bet and it could be
entertaining in the short run but very
consequential in the long term for what
happens with the Trump movement and
whether there is a trump movement going
forward Marjorie Taylor green
who was you know Q Anon follower
promoting violence Jewish space lasers
all this different stuff
she has started to reorient herself as a
voice of reason within the Republican
party she is presumably going to get
committee assignments back with um uh
Kevin McCarthy as Speaker of the House
she she is now becoming part of the
establishment Maga side she's still a
trump supporter but she's probably
realizing that Trump's power is
diminishing to some degree
she wants to transform herself
politically she's making the BET of I'm
gonna ease up a little bit on Maga I
support Trump but I'm part of this other
contingent
Lauren bowper on the other hand is going
full in with we are the defectors we
know what's really good for the country
these people like green and others they
might say they support the ultra Maga
Wing but when it came down to it they
acquiesced or maybe even they gleefully
went over to feeling like we're now in
power we are now the the the big the big
boys and girls or whatever you want to
say
one of the really great things about
bobert targeting green is it's going to
pull green back into the mud so she
can't wipe herself off and say I'm with
McCarthy now you know I'm uh you know in
the in the mafia you might say I'm now a
made man you know I'm in a different
category at this point he's a friend of
ours rather than just a friend of mine
you know if you've read books about uh
the mafia some of those terms make sense
Marge wanted to sort of be the rat
fleeing the the sinking ship after the
Trump riots failed on January 6th and
the Red Wave failed to materialize and
then Republicans argued with these 20 or
so of them uh resisting and resisting
she saw the opportunity to flee the
sinking ship but bobert is trying to
pull her back in and it's all good for
the left in the sense that the more
fractured this movement is I believe the
better it is for the Democratic party if
you disagree with me let me know one of
our sponsors today is zipx nicotine
toothpicks zipx brings you a convenient
alternative to smoking and vaping and
The Vape clouds the ash trays the thing
in your lip that people can see I've
seen that around this is an easier and
less messy way to curb the cravings and
you can use zipx just about anywhere
zipx is available in six flavors with
two or three milligram strength the
nicotine and the flavor are long lasting
and zipix has helped countless people
kick the bad habits and they are bad
habits zipx toothpicks are FDA
registered their customer service is
second to none it is one of the most
cost effective Alternatives also check
out their B12 and caffeine toothpicks
see for yourself why so many people have
switched to zipx 2 picks you can only
get zipx online go to zipxtoothpix.com
and get 10 off with the code Pacman the
link is down below